this is a production of Cornell
University
so today begins our our focus on
horticulture and the changing climate
and probably the best person to
introduce this topic to us is in the
room and that's David Wolfe from our own
department of horticulture David gave me
this nice bio I'll try to kind of do
snippets from it like many of us faculty
in the room David did his graduate work
at the University of California Davis
yeah no he's he's currently professor of
plant and soil ecology in the department
of horticulture he is co-chair of the
New York State soil health program work
team since 1990 he's been a leading
authority on climate change impacts on
proper soils and ecosystems with lots of
peer-reviewed publications and book
chapters and reviews and and all sorts
of things recently he was the lead
author for the agriculture chapter of
the Northeast climate change impact
assessment released July 2007 he is the
author of the award-winning popular
science book on soil ecology tales from
the underground the natural history of
subterranean life
and Neil and I discussed look there when
I could cover there's over the years I
have done various angles of research on
this and we could have dug deep on some
of those but I felt it was best for me
to kind of give an introductory
broad-spectrum discussion of some of
this I'll be touching a little bit on
some new work that will be publicly
released in early November the New York
state funded projects looking at the
vulnerabilities and adaptation
strategies for agriculture and for
ecosystems in the state's funded by the
organization and quite a number of
people at Cornell besides myself and dr.
Sears do you tip it some some of that
information there's a number of websites
on here I'll come back to them I think
in my final slide okay first time you'll
be hearing I think a little later in the
term from our day Gaetano the climate
scientist here at Cornell work closely
with over the years on all of this and
go give you a lot of details about
climate change science but I thought to
just start our session I'll talk a
little bit about climate change and the
actual science of changing climate per
se and put a little bit of perspective
for you this is the trace going back if
you concede from the back of the row to
400,000 years and the bottom is the
temperature trace looking at these we
can see these a different
sherbert rise in temperature these are
the interglacial periods take place over
tens of thousands of years so at that
going on you can see reasonably well
correlated with that we also have with
the change of temperatures to keep
greenhouse gases going up and down
methane and carbon dioxide I keep in
mind you know the stall going on well
before humans were very important on the
planet right right about here is where
even started human agriculture started
but put this in perspective way over
here
so yes the climates always been changing
humans aren't the only one nobody's
trying to say humans are the only ones
causing climate a lot of this is doing
art making into some of this with you
too planetary ships minor shifts of the
Earth's axis some activities and a lot
of this work is a scientist of
understood for some time some of the
driving forces of this but certainly the
greenhouse gases are are part of this
whole story now what I'm going to show
you in the next graph it's got the same
thing on the x-axis going down 400,000
years but it's going to show just the
co2 trace replace some of that nobody
was super co2 going again to kind of put
things in perspective so now it's a the
X the y axis is quite different but
here's that co2 trace we saw in the last
graph went back 400,000 years I've got a
different y-axis scale so it's all
shrunk down but you can see to go back
almost half a million years co2 never
really gets above 200 so your twos going
up and down yes even 40 minutes while
the planet it's going up and down but
right about here humans are on the
planet and they start affecting things
and I guess somewhere right about there
was when I was in grad school and co2
was about three hundred thirty parts per
million
390 parts per million now so you can see
we are out already and this is actually
a little out of date we have a little
bit higher
we're already due to human activities
fossil fuel burning and other things
moving to co2 levels beyond what we've
seen for the past 400 thousand years and
now the projections for the future look
like this
based on current rates of fossil fuel
emissions and based on the best
estimates that scientists have we have
kind of two scenarios that are typically
depicted the lower scenario would be one
of its within the next decade or two
society gets gets really moves quickly
away from energy products that release
co2 wherever greenhouse gases clean
energy if we don't do much in just week
see what happens and remember the co2
levels these all these fluctuations you
saw before their correlation with
temperature so you can see why this kind
of spooks us a little bit in perspective
I hear something a little more familiar
to you plant hardiness zone maps these
color-coded maps is the one for the US
on the left there 1990 USDA's last map
the the color codes refer to the coldest
against in the winter
mid one winter temperatures and garden
centers and farmers are aware of this
sort of thing the minimum winter
temperatures determine what kind of
watermelons
put in your garden but keep in mind also
minimal winter temperatures are very
crucial to for example to have a range
of insect insect pests and we're cops we
might go different places where weed
species will grow so that's the 1990 map
this is always been based on the last 15
years of weather records that's a very
laborious the very straightforward
procedure you look at all the NOAA
weather stations all the weather station
data same stuff we get the weather
reports from on the news in the evening
go back last 15 years and you look at
the minimum air temperatures and develop
these codes
we've done in 2006 they gave it from the
back of the room you can see no matter
where you live in the US we've had some
very dramatic change in minimum winter
temperatures in just that period of time
almost a met Iranian death in a
different running - so I've got a
project with the dear Botanic Garden
from the Bronx New Yorker a few years
ago they put in a test Garden of all
some more metals that party to stone
okay so that's the key thing there kind
of this pace of change is really not
something way beyond will be seen in the
last this kind of this is much faster
than the typical like what I was showing
earlier graphs interglacial
so one question is you know what species
will be able to keep up with this in
terms of moving around to stay in their
their ideal so I've taken even closer to
home this is some information on the
North East in particular and one thing
we notice in the Northeast is is that
we're experiencing you know warming just
like the global warming is happening
where our warming rate on an annual
basis is a slightly faster than the
average global warming but in particular
our winters are one more than our
summers and so winter temperatures I've
been the Northeast have gone up over
four degrees Fahrenheit on average
across the Northeast this is just
different colored dots different sized
dots indicating how much increase has
been from this period this was a
valuation from 1972 and I guess the key
thing is to see the matter where you
look on this map there's no bear showing
a decrease in temperature or
stabilization how much and I'm going to
put a whole lot of stock in exactly
where you live because there are some
issues with certain weather stations not
just
and this is what really fascinates me
what really has done me even deeper into
this whole issue as an ecologist plant
scientist recognizing that plants can be
looked at as very sensitive whether it's
difference might say and these living
things like plants are also responding
to the climate change we've already been
experiencing yeah Bo talking about
trying to predict the future you might
not just talk about what's been
happening and so myself and I like so a
number of other people two years ago
looked up some they're got some
historical records of bloom dates apples
grapes and lilacs throughout the
Northeast and documented that all three
of these perennial food crops in our
beach in our deep blooming earlier than
they did previously by as much as a week
or more species so and these are just
things we have records for we were also
seeing changes in rivals of butterflies
and insects and this is I won't take the
time to go through this is this a number
of peer-reviewed papers besides ours
documenting other things more or less in
our region more indicators the living
world already responding to the change
we're seeing diverse Arnold Arboretum
showing earlier bloom dates as well
about flowers and Washington DC in
climate change
because it seems to me that it's you
know fairly comes in from all sorts of
angles in terms of evidence that that's
already happened I mean you could say
you're not sure what the causes are but
certainly something's changing out there
now I'm talking about the future so Neil
mentioned briefly this Northeast climate
impacts assessment I was about some
years ago and there we had a whole team
of climate modelers I won't go into the
details and get part might fit into this
more with later the term and a whole
ensemble of the latest and greatest
GCN's global circulation models and also
regionally downscale these are region
came up with the best estimates they
could on what the future holds we are
not just looking at the past and to just
go to sort of the extreme end of things
looking at the end of the century again
sort of assuming two scenarios here
because the most difficult things
addicting the climate in the future is
not so much the physics of the climate
models but what a society going to do
we're going to go on this lower
emissions pathway or are we going to
kind of do this business as usual thing
and you can see even if you go on to
lower emissions pathway do relax in the
system and a lot of details
we'll find the response to pianists
asses and such we're looking at a few to
several degrees continued warming back
in the century and worst case businesses
usual we kind of just move along like we
are now and have to pay much attention
to it we could have as much as seven to
eleven or so put that in perspective of
this higher emission scenario thing for
for a hundred years from now or less
that amount of temperature change
well like we're sitting right now
fifteen thousand years ago was all under
a glacial ice sheet hundreds of feet
thick in some places and the temperature
was about twelve eleven degrees
Fahrenheit cooler than it is and over
the course of fifteen thousand years
it's warmed and we've got we've got now
we're talking about in a hundred years
with our winter temperatures in our
region there's all kinds of little
nuances and I'm just going to give you a
couple again just in terms broad
overview introductory talk one that sort
of intrigued me and then has to do with
the the effect of warmer winters has on
snow cover and this then affects albedo
reflectivity of the surface the more
snow you have the less warming that goes
on during the winter because the letter
that light is reflected back up when we
have warmer temperatures it feeds on
itself because you have less snow cover
your snow cover days it gets warmer and
warmer snow melts more and basically
that's why our winters are warmer than
our summers that's when the high
latitude regions
this graphic on the left is the red
outline of the Northeast there that map
shows the historical looking historical
records I think that was from 61 1990
the average the the region of the
Northeast where you had at least 30 days
of snow cover in the winter and then the
white area here a much smaller white
area is what's projected for end of
century how much of our region will
actually see at a minimum of 30 days of
summer by end of century and with the
business-as-usual snow he has we kind of
think of snow is cold but also of course
it's big insulating blanket in the
winter a lot of species are dependent on
that insulation for their winter
survival and a lot of microbial activity
actually stay keeps going through the
winter because just below us no blanket
temperatures hover around freezing but
you can still have a lot of nitrogen
mineralization and things like that some
of you may have been there long enough
to know just the ridge service a
graduate student of mine who had the I
got a tough project of having snow
removal plots versus no snow removal
plots a lot snow shoveling all winter to
look at what fewer snow-covered days
would mean for cell microbial community
structure in particular looking at the
nitrogen sacraments
and found that make a long story short
there was more nitrate leaching from
soils the floor snow cover because of
less smaller biomass lots of other
interesting things which I don't really
have time to get into but it affects
denitrification rates spring thaw I feel
office overweight rate of pathogens and
beneficial determination so all of this
climate happening and its projected to
happen a lot more impacts are going to
be our ecosystems are really undoubtedly
going to be doing some kind of level of
disassembly coming apart in some ways
some species benefiting from the change
some not some dying off dispersing to
other regions
and then reassembling in new ways and we
really it's I don't think you know we
just spend this major project this is
the maps on the left here are just
showing what could happen to some of our
major tree species groups for example
and this is based on a very simple
analysis just looking at how the basic
climate is going to change and how this
could affect a habitable zone of
different tree species so as the
habitable zone for certain tree species
is no longer an optimum it will be
disappearing in so this color code
in the upper left here you'll see a lot
of about gold
that's maple beech birch our maple
experts for us and if you look jump down
all the way to the far end of the end of
the century business as usual scenario
the severan little goal that New York
State very little maple beach perch in
other words the maple beech birch tree
communities could potentially disappear
from our region or begin to
significantly negatively affect in any
way by the planet well they really
disappeared well they know that this is
projecting that they would be replaced
by oak hickory pine type of course but
will the seeds of the open occurred pine
get up here complicated for example
let's just take the oak story is one
little interesting case it turns out
that deer are likely to benefit a lot
from climate change warmer winters less
snow cover they can eat more vegetation
in the winter and if there's trees
seedlings but they like to eat a lot as
a bunker so what Oaks can benefit in
terms of climate that can be fed out
more by the deer that are benefiting so
this is one example of how complicated
it is to predict our future but that's
that's kind of what we were going to be
dealing with because it's not like it's
some work to do I won't spend too much
time on this is some specific species
some two species likely to lose suitable
habitat again it could be a lot of other
confounding factors that affect this
the thing that concerns anybody who fix
about the interaction between species or
ecology of all of that it is one thing
we know for certain is there's no two
species out there that are going to
respond exactly the same complaint just
like probably no two humans are going to
respond exactly the same circuit up like
what's changes are happening in
something like that so that could affect
species interactions and as we have this
change in climate zones we also know
with great certainty that we're not
going to have entire complex ecosystems
the multiple species moving and mass
together staying coordinated there's
going to be a lot of a rupture of those
things and so how might that messed up
things like plants and pollinators
plants are blooming earlier
their natural enemies but here we have
there's really watering for a lot of
research minimal evidence of major
disruptions at this point there's some
redundancy in our ecosystems so a big
question mark there but something that
we think most feel this would be an
issue here there now let me move on on
to agriculture which all tend to focus
on more specifically
and if you talk to home gardeners and
farmers longer growing seasons and
warmer temperatures their eyes can light
up and think well I can grow camellias
here I couldn't grow them before I can
grow better watermelons we can do better
job with red wine grapes and in fact you
know there's certainly truth to this and
compared to some parts of the world we
will I think in our region there's a
literally a possibility they'll have
some real opportunities and here at
Cornell were all about working with
farmers to take advantage spending these
opportunities I think the tricky thing
for farmers is going to be not jumping
the gun on these things knowing and this
is where people at Cornell can help
resembles someone like Bart their
climate scientists providing more than
just anecdotal information about weather
weather trends are sort of part of a
real climate change but I'm an honor
system so we're very much about helping
farmers decide if they want to start
making some changes for gardeners
there's a downside to our region and me
we will if you look south of here and
you look at the weed pressures south of
here we look at the insect pressure the
disease pressure it's much greater than
we have here sweet corn growers in a
place like Laurel Florida of Georgia can
spray 15 times a year for some
Lepidoptera the past some years we
a couple sprays for example so pesticide
those could be an issue
summer heat stress while warmer
temperatures and summer can benefit some
crops we would certainly have more heat
stress of days and then I'll talk a
little bit more about water management
we could have sort of a situation here
where we have both too much in too
little water we're going to have climate
projections indicating perhaps both
sides of that coin just to take a
specific example for the bigger Finger
Lakes region and are the wine grape the
vanilla one grape industry this as we
all know been growing by leaps and
bounds since the 1970s or so just
coincidence related thicker fortuitously
for many of those people we've been
moving into this warming phase and a lot
of those European bits that are not
native to our region they can suffer
pretty severe damage at minus 12
Fahrenheit or less we used to have more
winters with those really low
temperatures we've had fewer since that
industry's been expanding and so really
I think I'm the projections are that we
should see continuation of that so I
think that industry is an industry where
there could be some potential but oddly
something we've been seeing lately is
more fruits damaged in some of our
different plant foods he pitted years
we've had one for winters now one of
winters I mean if we take the average
December those January February
temperature we can have a winter like
that where the average of those two
months of the winter is warmer and we
can still have more freeze damage than
we've seen in three days and this can
kind of come in - it can happen from two
angles
one is you can have an unusually warm
December which helps your average winter
temperature but then the plants don't
harden from or maybe they started to
harden in November then they come out of
this hardening process and then you have
a normal January and they get hard hit
by freeze which is what we saw in a
couple of years you can also have
prematurely pout in the spring I think
you might say speculative but I'm
actually will sort of gradually as a
century goes on grow out of this problem
but right now however some other regions
have worse you know think about what's
happening versus of the country in just
the world
in California that get even more serious
concerns I think about their food
industries Napa Valley so famous birds
one quality summer distress projections
there look very bad after maintaining
that same level of quality and later in
this term we're going to have to us
another thing it's a bigger issue
is here as supposed to give this room
would know a perennial food crops
actually need some cold temperatures in
winter in the spring you might say
temperatures go if they have to stay
below about 45 degrees Fahrenheit for so
many and this this graphic just shows
that in parts of different parts of
California that's coming up a big
problem for us maybe some of our late in
the century we might have some problem
with some of our apple varieties that
have very long winter chill requirements
some of you look at us those I mentioned
already is wonderful winters is going to
mean more overwintering survival of
March liova which took insect pests I
think it had more generations in the
summer season northward expansion of
their range invasive weed species
because new interview from the South
it's range is very much dictated by the
minimum winter temperatures so the corn
earworm is an interesting story would
already were kind of seeing some
adaptation you might say of agriculture
in my boutique where our IBM Scouts are
having to set out pheromone traps to
look for activity of Cornell work
earlier than they ever did before and
honors for adapting to that be more
focused if we deal as a vector of
Stewart's world
this is the graphic showing that the
spread of the kudzu range for example
into the Northeast and up top panel is
looking at the business's usual mission
scenario again many scenarios of fossil
fuel emissions versus the lower
emissions on the bottom early century to
the end of the century dark orange
this is kudzu coming to get us and you
can see it's marching up their efforts
to lower mission scenario would be much
less problematic for us while I'm
speaking of weeds and kutsu another
interesting phenomenon about weeds is
that it turns out that fast-growing
species in general such as our weeds are
tend to benefit more from the direct
effect of just the higher carbon dioxide
in the atmosphere so I suppose many of
you are familiar with this so-called co2
fertilization of that thanks take up co2
for photosynthesis to sugars to throw
and so most of our so-called c3 plants
with c3 photosynthetic pathway in
particular we have a potential to get
some some boost from higher co2 meows
irrespective of climate change and this
makes my I first got into the climate
change research
the species that tend to take the most
advantage of this and get the most
benefit are plants that can to put it in
simple terms find a place to put the new
sugars that producing the extra sugars
more quickly than they get the feedback
effects starting to slow down and for
synthetic capacity so you have this kind
of downward for synthetic acclamation
eyes co2 plants that don't get the sink
capacity before the new sugar sucrose
into the basketball leads really benefit
a lot this is Canadian thistle not only
do they benefit more but I probably lose
this Cup is that a lot of work with
beets and co2 is documented for a lot of
wheat species that it takes more they're
more resistant to herbicides control so
this is showing an experimental method
that Canadian thistle grown as a co2
levels versus two levels expected by mid
to late century same level of glyphosate
roundup sprayed on both had to go to two
to three times the recommended rate by
the safe against control so how will
farmers adapted gardeners adapt to this
it's great so this is our kind of a
conundrum and you know major issue that
you're you know time to learn
policymakers to I'm working both with
the Dec and active markets on time to
give everybody sort of poised about
climate change issues we can't be tying
the hands of farmers for definite
climate change on the other hand we have
to be proactive about this sort of thing
perhaps be proactive about developing
alternatives the chemicals for summer
heat stress even for crab like tomatoes
which currently is really you could
argue you know largely adapt attorneys
or the staff at some important made a
processing industry in some years in the
past but it's not perfectly suited
nervous so it should benefit some from
warmer temperatures but even today those
who get some high temperature stressed
or reproductive base and you have
terrible effects on quality etc and
there's no question any of the climate
model projections you look for are
relook at Pro region we will have
increased frequency of the number of
days that we're particularly concerned
about the dairy industry turns out that
dairy cows horticulture here and I had
to learn this from animal scientist
colleague letter chases years of change
dairy cows really like a cool like 40 to
70 degrees Fahrenheit
so we have to lower dairy industry has a
lot of challenges advantages don't have
to have dairy farms with a lot of fancy
cooling equipment and we have council
people that work at their people but
certainly this is show some model
projections sewing no production decline
of teacher for the Northeast
unless farmers do some fairly
straightforward adaptations improving
the ventilation system of the dairy
barns putting in more fans however this
is a capital cost you know one question
we have is will the farmers have that
capital to make that transition as many
of you know a lot of the dairy industry
as the farmers are right at the edge and
they might just assume sell out have to
come up with that kind of capital to
make the kind of adjustment and yet
there could be people from another
region of one more part of the country
look at this as an opportunity and so it
could exacerbate the already
consolidation we're seeing this is
showing up some details of the
projections for the Northeast
temperature on the top graph and
rainfall and there's a little warmth and
a little more detail and I
it's showing a few different climate
emissions scenarios different types into
the future what I really want you to
just look at is looking at if we look at
temperature you can see whether we look
at the annual temperature winter
temperature of the summer temperature no
matter what model were looking at or a
mission scenario we've got this general
you know temperature increase
precipitation that's a little different
well I guess the good news is that serve
the good news is the annual
precipitation for each it's not
projected to decline dramatically like
we see for other parts of the world so
they're now preparing a personal
question
yes it's a precipitation is harder for
modelers to predict so the data is a
little more bigger error bars often but
you might say looking at the data
available overall that precipitation
might stay constant but the increase
that we do see is likely to come in
winter and probably which the rain fall
down snow fall very little change in
summer so if we have warmer temperatures
it is summer and the exact same rainfall
what's that going to do to crop
evapotranspiration and properties
a compensatory increase in rainfall
aurelion to keep up with the warmer
temperatures to not have increased
requirements so even while we're not
conducting in our extreme droughts the
end of Agriculture in New York because
of drought I think there's going to be
more challenges Gordon more need for
irrigation I've got a couple other
slides to go into a little more detail
about the irrigation story or first this
is showing them just to inform you that
even today we kind of think of her New
York is having rainfall enough rainfall
for summer crop production but actually
in some parts particularly this is
looking at Rochester which is one of the
drier parts of the state but also very
important production area for example
looking at this is historical records
you can see that in these months here's
month six seven eight were to referring
to the middle of the summer this is
potential evapotranspiration
this is swimming pool can be covered too
by the way we have really like this but
the maximum potential evapotranspiration
exceeds that grateful in summer so
really you know to to go optimum crops
in Rochester New York AdWords point
average here mothers you might be able
to rely to something again take care of
some of this gap with water holding
capacity of the soil and brooding depth
but probably the lead supplement or
irrigation a lot of years and what our
models project for the future is that
this is going to become more dramatic of
course
this CIPA tations projected about the
same this graphic is a little tricky and
I'll point out just a couple things to
give you the key points so this is
looking at look to try to look into the
future and looking at b1 and a2 refer to
the two different emissions scenario and
this is looking later and later into the
century and this is again focus on
Rochester New York I was just showing
you an historic data and this is doing
an analysis for the historic data and
it's looking at these this color code
refers to how much was silver water
deficit and we could see that if you
look at this blue coat down in the
bottom here about one in ten years we
have absolutely no deficit plenty of
water for the season historically and
about 10 percent of the years we have a
pretty severe deficits where people have
irrigation but no way you're gonna have
up if you just look at this teal blue
color at the top here you can see that
as you might expect expanding more and
more of the years more frequency more
chances of this kind of severe gutter
since summer this is kind of a worst
case scenario we're doing future
analyses looking
this is assuming full can't be covered
for the whole summer which is kind of
worse case it's more just a very
historical to projected yeah I think
without question one think instead of
confidence is that irrigation price will
go up at the same time we have a current
trend for increased frequency of high
rainfall events more of our rain in the
northeast of the past 30 years or so is
coming down packaged in rainfall like
one to two inches in 48 hours and that's
projected to continue so so we're going
to get it from both angles in the
challenge for farmers is what do I do it
way I've had flooding the last three
years is the superlative phenomenon
should I invest $10,000 in a new trading
system or wake of the tummy drops going
to be happening when should I invest an
irrigation system and what they were
doing here at Cornell was trying to come
up with economic decision to a littles
laying out some different climates no it
was good
giving farmers the tools to try to make
this sort of decision that probably
didn't really have to their own personal
level
so adaptation that kind of alluded to
some of these there's all kinds of
things farmers can do to deal with
climate change from fair to simple ones
new crops new varieties and more
diversified farms earlier planting dates
with river Springs changes the pruning
strategies obviously more better we pest
monitoring as we have news pests coming
up increased irrigation improving
drainage animal facilities improve the
improve the cooling certainly for
example a dairy barn being built today
that's a big long-term investment could
be a 1500 year investment
she'd not be built on the specs of the
old historical climate that we know was
not going to eat here that kind of thing
is some farmers we do have this issue of
equity concerns annual small family
farmers found a little bit of capital it
might take to make the adaptation that
could keep them in business or even open
up an opportunity for them in all of
these climate change assessments they're
sort of these three components that we
think about we've got a climate factor
like drought okay heat stress we've got
an impact you know reduced yields or
milk production decline and then an
adaptation
for example the climate factors we've
done you know we're used to the climate
scientists usually provide their
information with different levels of
certainty so they say well we with the
temperature projections we are pretty
hard to be certain about that
precipitation but we also have different
levels of certainty about the impacts
and then our adaptation to crashes so we
have to keep those things in mind as
well some impacts are very
straightforward if you don't water to
crop and doesn't get any moderates I can
do well some are much more subtle and
complicated for example co2 effects and
interactions mental stress and then
there's a tightening some of these
things I mentioned are happening now
today it's urgent we're going to respond
we need to be adapting now some are
projections that late in the century
and maybe which are chilling
requirements of some long winter chill
requirement apple varieties by end of
century might be getting on the edge
well that's later terms so those kinds
of things have to be kept in mind and
then sometimes we have a very
straightforward adaptation strategy but
there see there back though money to do
it farmers don't have the money or we
don't have the information to do it well
instead so we have to think about all of
these things as in poisoning the farmers
that will work with to be prepared for
this
okay it might be a few minutes remaining
able to turn a little bit of attention
to the other side of the coin and that
is not adaptation and how farmers might
adapt to climate change but mitigation
you might say becoming part of the
solution reducing greenhouse gases on
the farm this is a laundry list of some
fundamental things that can be done on
the farm a lot of these are the same
kind of things we'd be doing in our
personal lives and reducing fossil fuel
use etc using more renewable energy
little props window handling and storage
is a big one I'll mention some of these
in a little more detail nitrogen
fertilizer use efficiency I'll explain
why that would be a big one up there and
then sell carbon sequestration some of
your
so I'm going to talk about a few of
these these issues of the other side of
the coin will here I think a little bit
more about this so they have a lot of
farmers look this is because it makes
plenty of economic sense wind turbines
on marginal parts of the property to
supplement their own energy needs is
energy cost go up farmers exploding
biofuel crops users worth their own
needs or to the market center opening up
and well there's a lot of you know
obviously set our series about value
crops than having some a lot of
controversies and issues there's no
question that you know compared to
bringing new carbon from deep in the
earth and getting it up to the surface
and then burning it off and now that's a
part of our service system long term
there's a lot of advantages to working
with cycling of carbon to plants burning
the carbon from the plants
you know it was bits at the beginning I
you know I did a lot of the soils
biologists told ecology and this is
quite relevant I think cell biological
processes to the role that agriculture
plays in all three of the big greenhouse
gases we've got carbon dioxide n2o is
nitrous oxide and methane ch4 these are
the three biggest supreme house gases
for the most important in terms of
what's causing climate change and co2
emissions in terms of agriculture a lot
of it has to do with organic matter
decomposition just aerobic carbon
mineralization and when we talk about
things like let's reduce tillage to
sequester more carbon well when you kill
a soil your earrings feeding lots of
pumping lots of oxygen into the soil
stimulates this process it actually
burns off that organic matter so fast
that it doesn't really have time to do
us much good in terms of its beneficial
effects on the solar qualities so health
just burning it right back up and
putting it back up with co2 so we don't
want to over till next oxide emissions
this is sort of a diagrammatic way of
laying out the nitrogen mineralization
cycle from biota or crop residue being
converted to ammonium by microbes then
being converted to nitrate by other
microbes and after anaerobic conditions
you can get denitrification back up to
into completing the nitrogen cycle all
of this soil microbial activity
crucial to all of these what I wanted to
point out with this graphic is that
nitrous oxide is sort of a happenstance
offshoot of this very natural process
but the more nitrogen they put on either
as ammonium nitrate synthetic fertilizer
or the more manure we put on here we're
going to crank this cycle more more MORE
and the more you run through the cycle
the more volume of nitrogen fertilizer
we have going through this whether it's
organic or inorganic the more nitrous
oxide emissions so this is why nitrogen
fertilizer uses probably the key reason
why we're having exponential rise in
nitrous oxide in the atmosphere so
agriculture the key a key player in a
vet important peanuts caps and find the
methane emissions we all hear about the
burping of cows right that's anaerobic
bacteria advantage in to live in the
gutter towns also those kind of
bacterial have been rice so anaerobic
conditions and wetlands and mice many
fields some a fan of genesis both
lifestyle
there's also methane emissions from
breakdown of manure as well so tillage
and so health I already mentioned
reducing tillage is one approach to
increasing so carbon sequestration my
current Gradstein Sam Bosco is working
on a very difficult problem of if
farmers are going to begin try to
develop new accounting tools for keeping
track if they're going to reduce tillage
are they really doing what they think
they're doing in sequestering more
carbon in their soils how do we actually
measure the carbon in soil steeply
cost-effectively as those of you who
know this kind of work you know you can
take a room this size and you can
probably spend a career getting so of
course measurement carpet is still not
sure you got it right so how do we make
some guesstimate so carbon on a pretty
big landscape farm scale begin do they
do that accounting and it's it's tricky
and there's a lot of compromises that
have to be but where we had many others
around the country are working on it one
thing in terms of if they build some
strategic approaches to so sampling
usually starts with developing some maps
and just characterizing and stratifying
across major vegetation types of soil
types of courses might think about so
ideal sampling scheme one problem with
trying to get at the actual carbon
sequestered and so we actually have to
have a bulk density measurement as well
so we can't just measure carbon
concentration from a slope or we have to
get undisturbed quarters to do density
very labor intensive
but turkey and also we have to go to
deeper depths to really know what's
happening to soil so what we're really
doing is developing geospatial models
where we're coming up with some very
cheap and expensive things that we can
vendor that we're using visible to
near-infrared spectroscopy misprints
which once you get the system going you
can actually have a tractor mounted
device with a sickle that's kind of
going down through the soil and flashing
light in the soil getting reflectivity
from that looking at the wavelength
reflectivity and using that to estimate
so carbon and developing models to its
limits so covered change in the future
of a farmer's related markets so a lot
going on there oh that's the story of
night Regina I already talked about the
nitrous oxide emissions apart nitrogen
fertilizer used so so we've all been
hearing for many years about the
importance of being efficient with our
nitrogen use in terms of reducing the
nitrate pollutants into our ground
waters and surface waters at cetera and
this is just another incentive of
climate change
they're both nitrous oxide emissions and
also synthetic nitrogen fertilizers and
that's which are using their very
energy-intensive to manufacture many of
them for six tons of carbon emitted in
the atmospheric co2 equivalent submitted
in the atmosphere per ton of nitrogen
manufacturers so just buying a bag of
nitrogen fertilizer as a farm worker
this is showing up a table with looking
at some different components to a mix
dairy crop system and the co2 the
nitrous oxide methane emissions
everything from fertilizers use to the
numerous men when they were enameling a
decomposition hoop thing I wanted to
point out is that as we often see is not
the co2 emissions that a big part of
recovery budget for the markets and
nitrous oxide emissions so it's not the
tractor driving in the gas clear on the
back of the tractor a lot of estimate of
nitrogen management so important thing
we're turning some educate farmers about
a lot we can do in terms of nitrogen
management going back to our leggings
recycling Harold is as in others at
Cornell but I'm involved in semester
sweet corn
developing new approaches
management using soft models that type
of data
eat more efficient and that's not forget
we had what were three million acres of
turf in New York State and a lot of that
should all recognize this picture and as
I often said my cropping systems ecology
class I think this is really a big
challenge for agricultural scientists of
this century in the past century we
figured out how to decouple animal of
crop production systems for economies of
scale etc it's been good for economics
but we need to somehow come back and
think about how to still maintain
profits for farmers keep the economies
but every couple and begin to utilize
these resources like anaerobic digesters
are important solutions to and farmers
are very interested in this thing it
reduces their cost of production
so rubbing our chalice kind of move
there's a couple summary slides first of
all I think we have to get over the
notion and really the first generation
of people that have to do this is
something that the past historical
climate rotary live is is what we should
be basing our decisions so this our
generation is really could be channels
to develop new approaches to
environmental monitoring things like
where are the insect pests moving where
is the climate changing where we need a
lot of these new decision tools it's not
just enough to know but something's
happening it's like if your people are
talking about a farmer making an
investment in something and then I think
you can do it to come up with these
win-win strategies for I think this
there's a lot of enthusiam enthusiasm
among farmers for this I was just
involved in leading every 10 years or so
the land-grant universities get together
all the science
the big issues I was asked to lead a
group of people around the country
developing the climate change piece of
fact that is for what it's worth some of
the big research areas laid out of
course climate science issues better
regional downscaling more weather based
decision support for the farmers another
research area that surprisingly better
models for leads and cats particularly
specialty crops which is our culture
their specialty their special everything
besides corn soybean I guess a very
important one I think is economic
assessments not just what the impacts
might be or it might cost decision
science and decision support tools how
do we really how do people really make
those changes what makes people make
certain kinds of decisions other people
change the behavior whatever people need
for decision support some very deep
bodily the more complex entire food shed
networks and that kind of thing
various things we can think about blood
of these are fairly straightforward
adaptation strategies breeding crops for
more of my temperature stress drought
stress through water management on
chemical options we need these for the
mitigation piece we need to come up with
some new tools for farmers to begin to
be able to
I don't think agriculture the long run
it's going to be the only industry
exempt from having to it gradually
eventually to get to working part of
their system having some information
about whether its market opportunity for
them or it has to do with monetary
communication and of course policy
issues so these were just what a group
of people from the US scientists came up
with for some of the big issues okay
so I think that should tell stuff here
there's a bunch of people this is just a
partial list of people I've worked with
for a lot of this I think I mix it with
there's some funders northeast airs
Monday let us work in the serta
organization these websites that Cornell
has a climate change website to remember
take a look at a climate in farming org
has a lot of PowerPoint slides
this is that northeast Leonard impacts
assessment report this sa p43 is the
most recent US National Assessment
chapter and then the Intergovernmental
Panel on Climate Change the main source
of all
so we just eat the dairy scientists I
don't know that's a big challenge but I
think you know what we really need are
some creative you know I think it's
there's the best as one of the stumbling
blocks yeah another big one there been
third big one and the other big one is
just the bulk of the material you know
and moving around and so I think for
those two big big challenges that's what
the guys in this room are going to
figure out
I think one thing is you know creating
incentives that would make it create
opportunities for business entrepreneurs
whether it's some minimal level of
processing gets resolved some of these
things or new ways of handling things or
some other strategies but it can also be
you know just wait the degree to which
we maneuver is just integrated with
other parts of this but I don't have the
answer to
you're right it's a big challenge yes
but of course it's from my Geneva I see
some hands here infection they kind of
involves my questions well I didn't give
more more interested care systems and
one thing that I've kind of seen is that
it's not necessary that we don't have
the technology where the people that can
figure it out is that we don't have the
financial backing or the policies in
place you can design the newer digesters
that can ball flies off nitrogen
precipitate out of phosphorus yeah and
you're done I mean it can't be that hard
if you just mix limestone or drop raise
the pH and phosphorous if that stuff
we're generating electricity on farm
they're selling that electricity back to
the grid at four cents a kilowatt hour
and they have to buy it back at thirteen
cents yeah so it doesn't make any sense
for dairy farmers to install you know
one of these turbines when they're
losing eight cents per kilowatt hour so
you know which is going to the
governor's office issues in there
there's engineering coming up with
people who are talking about those
things
yeah and I think it's you know really
important part of the portfolio and one
thing we're going back to this climate
actually Council one thing we're
thinking about is this you know
something like 90 percent of the timber
land in New York State is effectively
owned and one thing we like from a
climate change perspective what you'd
like to see is incentives for those who
have the trees not to be cutting it down
because that's
they're happening you know
back-of-the-envelope calculations done
on how many acres and lamb going to take
how much new tree planting we have to do
through here globally to keep up with
the co2 emissions projected and it's
it's it's out of sight and you know
we're not going to solve the problem
just like we're not gonna solve problem
by substituting some biofuels but it
could certainly be part of them
and you know trees at least advice
sometimes we have 50-year 100-year that
window sequestration of carbon
eventually a little that covered me in
definitely decomposing and going back in
the atmosphere 100 years from now you
saved ourselves so there's very
important that so we have vegetation
cover has a big big affect different
types of vegetation cover have effects
on healthy toe and there's a few people
in the country
so ERISA attract worth looking to hire
to Cornell an interest or
biogeochemistry but they look focused be
kind of an ecologist a person but focus
very much on vegetation in solar
radiation someone during solar radiation
levels against the city say less
radiation with moisture in the
atmosphere or more cloud levels well the
solar radiation and I think in general
we the assumption is you know the solar
radiation is not going to change
dramatically in the next hundred years
but there is there's some discussion in
the literature about the so called
global dimming phenomenon which refers
to the notion that kind of comes from
this notion that as the planet heats in
general more of the water that's on the
surface of the planet does get up into
the air above this water vapor and this
could be slightly diminishing solar
incoming solar radiation but all of that
has to do but at the same time the air
temperature is going up so it has a
higher water holding capacity before you
actually get that dimming effect make a
long story short you can't project that
very well so but there's a so anyway so
there could be some of that phenomenon
over the climate models and the various
types of climate models handle cloud
cover differently and there's a range of
some variability and how they handle
that but it's it's it's still within the
envelope of the projections I've showed
you
sort of fall into place so although it
creates a you know create some of our
variability what we projected in the
future I think we have we're talking
about expecting if it's the question is
our sunspots or something can save us
that's pretty very very optimistic you
know there are some activity things that
have caused these interglacial cycles
you know sometimes seen the new someone
coming out and saying oh it's sunspots
and they're talking about these
interglacial cycles and there's no
indication then all of a sudden the
interface you know we got on our way to
the next ice age
give us 30 40 thousand years so but the
moisture in the air on the first one to
show it looks like there's a pretty
predictable rise and fall temperature
every hundred thousand years or so so
going into studying you know it's kind
like a tipping bucket water on the
events that all of a sudden precipitate
the decline and are we just shortening
that time period before we hit that that
trigger that starts to bring the other
way but we just condensing the cycle or
yeah well I think I think why don't you
I would say I could I think I know the
answer the question would you ever say
that for our day gitanos their climate
scientists but you know I think those
those long-term cycles are have been
well studied I think the class I just
think they've got a handle on it has to
do with planetary
like that and there is also a fee
forward and feed back and forth between
co2 and temperature that we're seeing
now as the temperature begins to rise
due to rise in co2 caused by human
activity now we're seeing more co2 guys
because we're melting permafrost and
that's releasing more greenhouse gases
etc so that's why those two coincide
feed on each other back and forth so it
creates those cycles but I don't think
there's any evidence that we're
condensing that cycle I think those are
that cycle is Duke's a well-known
forcing factors that are in the global
general circulation models that they
used today and they operate on these
twenty thirty thousand forty thousand
years
seconds and all we're expecting now is
that we're pumping a bunch of greenhouse
gases sort of out of nowhere I have deep
in the earth unexpectedly and we're just
going to bump the temperature up rapidly
and that's staying that same driving
force bringing us towards an ice age is
going to continue but it's going to be
starting at a higher place so I don't
keep this up I thought that glacial
interglacial periods are convincing it's
more just we're just
any other questions from Geneva
those high positions yeah well there's
this sort of a range of various
projections about what climate change
might do that are I would put them in
the category of possible but not you
know that things that we feel had a
confident about but not not just crazy
ideas there within the realm of
possibility based on what we know and
that's certainly one of them at a place
like England could actually get colder
because the Gulf Stream is affected
which brings this warmer is warmer ocean
waters to it again the you know I could
I would be getting sort of an amateur
explanation of it where whereas climate
science is coming it later more detailed
answer but that's that's a real
phenomenon possibility same thing we
know that the sea level rise I didn't
get into that because it doesn't affect
our evolution we are state that
dramatically but we've got dramatic
CWI's it's a real phenomena day from for
example New York City are birds about up
about fifteen inches in the last 50 60
years and expected to continue even just
with thermal expansion
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu